let's go down a branch of law and see
where it takes us the point of this
series is to give characters meaning and
depth to bring part of the story back to
life you would have first noticed the
architect's act as you travel through
the shrine of Amana little is known
about the order though they're well
honed miracles and unwavering faith in
the face of death made them worthy
rivals to drangleic forces in their day
the magic of the arc trach was very
powerful especially if you versed them
before the patch these men and women
were a part of a sect which means that
they are an offshoot of a larger
religion or group in this case the arc
Drake's are a sect of lindelt
which is a country known for its clerics
and miracles so the arc Drake's are a
small separate religion to the main
religion of Lyndell but you want to know
what's most interesting about the arc
Drake sect they're hiding something the
secrets of lindelt rituals are protected
by the arktech sect and only a select
few are given access to their canon of
knowledge which includes the truthful
origins of the arc Drake sect itself I
think from has given us the clues to
trace the arc Drake sects origins it's
never explicitly stated where they're
from but there are so many hints and it
all starts with the description of the
shield that teases us with their origins
the slumbering Dragon shield long ago in
a city named silver there was a race
that discovered a great slumbering
dragon worshiped its magnificence and
perished by its side silver was a city
founded on miracles and faith in an
ancient dragon as such the development
of its sorceries was stunted as they
were considered taboo
similarly in lindelt a country known for
its clerics and their miracles sorcery
was believed to be a profane practice
but as with anything such beliefs apart
faith and part front hypocrisy the
secrets of lindelt rituals came to be
protected by the archaic sect and the
fact that the two countries shared the
same hypocritical distaste of sorceries
definitely helps link the two together
so if the slumbering Dragon shield
places the ark Drake's in silver then
how did the architects leave to become a
part of Lin delt while they must have
left Shova and with the invasion of the
Drake blood Knights they would have had
good reason to the Drake blood Knights
led by Sir jörg invaded silver and
fought with its inhabitants these
Knights worshipped the blood of dragons
and they were led by so your Guinness
age to murder sin the slumbering dragon
when the slumbering dragon was pierced
however he awoke and spewed poison over
all of silver
the drake blood nights are relevant
because their leader su jörg has a ring
that bares the crest of joan lake and i
mentioned this because their arc trachs
had a confrontation with drangleic the
arc direct staff states they're well
honed miracles and unwavering faith in
the face of death made them worthy
rivals to drangleic horses in their day
so if the drake blood Knights are from
drangleic then these descriptions tie in
nicely together the drake blood knights
invade to kill sin the slumbering dragon
the arc Drake Knights continue to fight
with faith in the dragon even though the
source of their faith is raining down
death upon them it also says in their
day which implies that the Ark Drake
Knights had a time when they stood alone
rather than as a sect if you've watched
my prepare to cry video on vel start
then you'll know that I think while
start of drangleic must have existed in
silver at some point since there's a
mirror image of him down in the depths
so if that's true it's likely that some
Ark Drake Knights managed to leave
silver as well joining drangleic with
val start and making their home in the
holy country of lynn delt and I'm
assuming Lynn delt and drangleic are
both countries under the same monarchy
for the Ark Drake Knights make their new
home in the shrine of Amana below
drangleic castle and it's also worth
noting that the Ark Drake Knights Inn
shrine of Amana are actually called Ark
Drake pilgrims and the word pilgrim is a
word with a lot of religious
connotations essentially meaning that
you have to go on a quest to a distant
land to prove yourself so it could also
mean that they're in shrine of Amana
because they're on pilgrimage from
lindelt
and here in the shrine of Amana we find
some of the biggest links to show
so even if I'm wrong about how they got
to the shrine even if you don't agree
with me on that where they came from
seems pretty set given all the
connections a simple observation to
start with is how similar the shrine of
Amana is to silver it's Underground its
dimly lit and it's got shallow water
actually the perfect example is the
demon of song room which is remarkably
similar to the lair of the imperfect
speaking of the demon of song silver and
the shrine of Amana are two places where
a demon and its priestesses sing to
soothe the inhabitants silver had a Dark
Queen singing with her priestesses to
soothe the dragon in its slumber and
Amana has a demon of song singing to the
mill finito
to soothe the dead for the Ark Drake
nights in Amana the slumbering dragon
continues to be the focus of their faith
the source of their miracles the Ark
Drake shields are all inscribed with
Dragons as a wave the Ark Drake's
to perform their rituals and all the
item descriptions that say that they
keep their rituals and origins a secret
say that because they are intricately
tied to one another their rituals and
their origins would be one of the same
lastly there is a bonfire named the
tower of Prayer in both silver and the
shrine of Amana which is what I'm going
to leave you guys on so maybe this video
gave you the sources to make your own
story about the arc Drake nights maybe
you believe that my telling of the story
is right or if nothing else I hope I
made you realize that there's more depth
than you might have seen here at first
glance all of these connections are
implied and No description concretely
states that there's a connection between
silver and drangleic so why do I believe
it well it's because this is exactly the
subtle stuff from wants us to dig for
and you can say it's coincidence but I
prefer to think that there's too many
connections for it to be a coincidence
and after hearing me talk you might
agree or disagree but hey that's the
beauty of it all just because I'm
pointing our connections doesn't make it
true what matters is what you believe
this video relates to my prepared
crayons in the slumbering dragon and my
prepare to cry on they'll start the
Royal Aegis and now that you've seen
this you'll probably understand more
about those stories and you'll
understand what was going on in the
background of those two tales so go
check those ones out there arguably a
little bit better produced than this
video but enjoy guys and if I don't have
a video out in the next few days Merry
Christmas Happy New Year and hope great
holidays I'll see you next time
you